[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was jiske was dead to begin with as dead
as a doornail in life was jiske was
business partners with a shrewd
totalitarian in ebenezer YouTube
[Music]
he was a tight-fisted hand at the
grindstone old Ebony zur YouTube a
squeezing wrenching censoring throttling
covetous old sinner
[Music]
yes sir mr. Ebenezer YouTube service
these days he's a partner sir and I
believe he's here to discuss your recent
deep monetization in that child
yes mr. YouTube's sisa will follow the
new changes with the advertising
algorithm you have channels real hard
sir we came against meet mimosa
mr. holiday sir it's my wife Lord she's
sick it's alums Dean acting right sir
the [ __ ] can't breathe could you just
please explain to me the new policy sir
so you know so nichkhun her living
against a shout you want to make
anything over YouTube yes sir mr.
YouTube sir I mean I've been doing it
for years so it's oh my gosh you made a
living off youtube before you fell oh
you were living now oh whoa no mr.
YouTube sir you don't know us [ __ ] I
just want an opportunity to earn living
again I could used to sir see sir nobody
understands the undisclosed policy sub I
was here from the very beginning you
know all you had was a bunch of cat
videos yeah now Marsh Maggie
ENL camera well of course sir there's
always those sir oh thank heavens for a
moment I was worried I've worked really
hard so I have over three million
subscribers if I don't figure out this
all guerilla my videos mass won't be
Dana if you rather your videos
don't let me burden and decrease the
surplus population
what the [ __ ] you gonna let this talk to
us like that me shut up [ __ ]
maybe what you talk about me we didn't
then he said oh let other times we spin
like YouTube channel assists shut up man
you acting like a damn live well many
they did we put you to work so even jobs
before you chose to grow your business
bone vesting in YouTube I'm a platform
with your time and money that's not my
business not your own not your business
[ __ ] of crazes here you let shut up
no be quiet now Jamba Juice it'd be a
little bit no making it shut up shut up
you know what I got some for you yeah
you'll see that we go right what but mr.
Ebenezer YouTube sir this crisp I'll
having time to make myself a Merry
Christmas and I certainly haven't talked
to make idle people merry and if I had
my way every fool who went about with
words Merry Christmas on his lips but
they boiled with his own pudding and
buried with the sake of Holly through
his heart
mr. cravaack I want ice demoralization
reports on my desk
we're quite hatched yes sir mr. YouTube
yes and find us a legal way to shut down
maca but mr. YouTube sir we have no
jurisdiction over model at mr. Cratchit
it's a pipe cutting off the platform
that allows these Street legends to
upload more free content than ever all
my platform on YouTube so you just don't
want them to make a living at all don't
find yourself a never live in June if
you don't do as I say crush it yes sir
mr. YouTube I'll find a way to make sure
no one makes a living off of that
content sir
they'll be wanting the whole day
tomorrow suppose if it would be
convenient sir it is decided and not
committed if I would have helped your
day's wages public you free yourself we
are used
it only comes once a year sir the poor
excuse for picking a man's pocket every
December 25th have the demonization
report on my desk Kolya yes sir yes sir
thank you mister sir after closing his
shop for the evening
Emma knees our YouTube walked his
melancholy self through the cold
melancholy streets until he found
himself at a familiar melancholy home it
was old enough now and dreary enough for
nobody lived in it but Evan easer
YouTube himself for darkness was cheap
and Ebenezer YouTube liked it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well in life I was your former partner
YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki sushi is that
ready Oh [ __ ] Howard he said it was me
a wall here hey oh you are in this
terrible change
oh I formed these chains in life due to
my misleading business practices my
censorship in general malfeasance even
easier I came to warn you
your chain was as big as mine when I got
here and you've been adding to it oh
you've got a big-ass chain hobo here to
[ __ ] you don't watch history it's big
comfort to me did you say comfort
I got again area these chains forged in
hell are kinda noisy oh you'll be
visited by three spirits there's still
hope for you Evan either you do expect
the first spirit when the Bell Tolls one
fresh spinach couldn't make them all
want to get over it oh don't be a dick
the spirits will come on the breaking of
a new hour of spinning Oh Evan easy
change your way don't be it they're
Japanese are you do
don't be a dick you are always such a
dick
don't be that dick as ominously as the
spirit had appeared so it vanished into
darkness and ebenezer YouTube retired to
bed humbug
Susan was jizz Keys ghosts that bother
Devin either YouTube exceedingly it was
a restless night and upon resolving that
he could no more fine sleep and go to
heaven the clock broke upon his
listening here oh you spirit whose
coming was fought out I am you're just a
girl oh you're so sweet I can remember
more than 15 years I'm the ghost of
YouTube paths business have you here
then your welfare and to help you stop
being a dick so take heed come spirit
I'm immortal
don't worry a touch of my hand and you
can follow as well a touch of your hand
well for safety's sake
[Music]
we are back to 2005 the launch of
YouTube
oh yes P 2005 I was a boy here a young
man indeed everyone was having a great
time it didn't suck yeah oh yes this was
a choice like there are my first
partners cheddar and Steve too many
there can never be too many everything's
allowed on the platform or it doesn't
work it's free and open cheers today how
foolish we were spirit before you had
any idea back then but we know now these
are merely shadows of the past they
can't hear you
I see no fools before me only men who
wanted a free and open platform
besides you were already bigger than
myspace Marsh spice traded their own
downfall we're never came a safe haven
for pedophiles if I've known back then
we all know now these people wouldn't
have a job posting of us programmatic
videos
it's a miracle we can go belly-up you
see this is the environment that made
YouTube what it is the freedom of it the
fairness heads likes comments these are
the things that made YouTube great and
push the best people to the top it was a
meritocracy let me show you something
I sound all critics place
and who's this board tiny tiny tiny not
AJ I mean okay Jared a tip of fit time
YouTube inspired this boy if not for
your platform he'd still be a homeschool
child was nothing more than Warren
McGann me videotapes
instead he learned how to live stream is
video games with you our platform he's
been able to get billions of views and
support the whole Cratchit family I did
not know the cratchits were in such need
spinner a remarkable night and a gross
violation of child labor what's going to
say Baba I'm so glad you're home you
work so hard in for such long hours Oh
little one you shouldn't worry about
that you just get your rest and take
your mess but father I have over 1
million subscribers on YouTube and
YouTube says as the partnership program
grows it'll pay more and more as bigger
sponsors come in soon you won't have to
work for Evan easier told Oh tiny not
gay Jared you're such a dreamer you
should be teaching us all
[Music]
there was another Christmas I remember
spirit
please do not show me that question this
is a Bearnaise of YouTube's viral video
compilation 2015
Khalid bit my finger I am
[Music]
the plastic cap go down the steps
oh please Ryan Maya hey Maya Frankie
Friday Friday
[Music]
I'm back Oh spirit want you to like me
tormenting me these are the shadows of
things that have been they are what they
are do not bathe me just as quickly as
it appeared the spirit faded from view
and ebenezer YouTube found himself once
again in his chambers unsettled and
unrest 'add awaiting more operations to
come restless and still pondering the
lessons of the first spirit it wasn't
long before Ebenezer YouTube found
himself awakened by yet another
apparition
[Music]
well hey are you the ghost of Christmas
present yeah
[Music]
should I come in I know you better man
love you one I must say if you had a
quite met anyone not you spit Roy well
in 1800 of my brothers have come before
me 1800 ah what a precedent precedence
[Music]
precedent is a legal opinion upon which
other legal opinions are based
precedence is about priority and order
of yes of course
teach me tonight's lesson spirit I'm
prepared to learn
no fine touch my robe I'm not entirely
comfortable it's not like that don't be
a dick you got to touch my robe in order
to get this transport thing look just
come on right now
[Music]
[Music]
you free its roommate Channel do you
want to play a game me obviously okay
let's play a game of yes or no I'll be
it okay what's trending on YouTube right
now guess is it spin Shapiro
no is it Reuben certainly not is it
louder with crowd be silly wait is it an
unwanted video always is it wildly
unpopular of course so it's not Shapiro
it's not Reuben it's an unwanted video
but it's trending anyway why it's
BuzzFeed boldly painting in period bless
[Laughter]
oh I never meant to have my own nephew
you must understand the first read women
painting in period blood had to take
precedent precedence look it doesn't
even matter
we've got Morrissey let's go oh she's
Pierre I can't bear any more
show me no more come on let's go
[Applause]
spirit ed sound got credits house yes Oh
father come and see my latest video has
plays in just three hours such a make it
faced I'm very appreciated
what is it
it's already been demonetised already
they seem to be getting demonetized
faster this time of year such a
remarkable child indeed
tell me spirit what does he have that is
a question for the future it's not my
gig but I will tell you that if these
shadows remain unaltered ergo you don't
stop being a dick the child will die Oh
tell me he can be safe Esther well
except shoot my time on this earth is
very brief sorry joke especially a film
it's offering so much from you yeah how
could stand to learn me the rest is for
the ghost of Christmas yet to come
Oh tell me speak this is 20 not get
Jared I have to die well if you'd rather
die then he better do it and decrease
the surplus population do you remember
your memories of learning you it was a
callback to the things make sure you
remember okay do you want to see her my
room alone with his thoughts
Evan ease our YouTube found himself
cloaked with dread for he knew what
awaited him next
petrified Lebanese or YouTube found
himself to be a praying man in a futile
attempt to bargain with death but he
feared it to be a fruitless endeavor 40
disappointed to a man once to die
[Music]
well you let spirit of YouTube yet to
come
Oh spirit I feel you more than any
Specter Viet Minh but I am prepared to
fight for thankful will you know speak
to me oh yes it's not just waiting fast
they don't spirit
my video got three million vanes and
only 48 hours where'd you do that I
uploaded it to vignette form or praise
of your bloating gap oh bugger off with
gap vimeos players been top now for
years that's where you go if you want to
be seen but twitch has the better
interface but Vimeo has but two eyeballs
but gap has the most open platform well
you could always just go I understand
spirit this destiny of YouTube might be
of my own doing
should I continue on my path now show me
some tenderness in this world
Robin haunted by the terrible
conversation forever
Oh your spit shankar crusher D'Antoni
doctor Jared's house oh this is a place
of great joy and laughter thank you for
bringing me here it's so quiet why is it
so quiet spirit
[Music]
[Music]
no spirit the aged spirit must there be
an awful Christmas it brings about the
sing like this how could we do it
spirit must we return to this place or
is this something else I must know is
that not true
[Music]
spirit I must ask are these the shadows
of YouTube that 100 milli the shadows of
YouTube that may be okay
why would you talk about miss Ferrett if
these events cannot be changed
[Music]
a website can be made right
attributive can be changed
[Music]
changed my platform
[Music]
deniz our YouTube awakened to find
himself in a familiar place yes it was
so the bed was his own the curtains were
his own the room was his own how much
giddy as a schoolboy
okaywe oh come Merry Christmas everyone
Oh merciful heavens I will make things
right I shall make amends all three
spirits of YouTube now live within me I
saved on my knees I'm Susan Wojcicki on
my knees Oh heaven
give up on fellow what days today me
what day is today
you don't know what there is was that
Christmas Day bow it's Christmas Day why
I haven't missed it the spirits did it
all in one night course it's course
equipment what a remarkable young lad
don't add do you know that Olmec hanging
an earful show-window
Rena bloody huge one that's as big as me
best one
an intelligent remarkable young cadet go
and fetch it for me bring it to the
Cratchit house and I'll give you
shilling that's all those things
demolition city minutes I'll give you
after prep with no money
a lovely lateral weevil throw me a
credit card have blind trusting and hope
I come back I saw you go me a big
intuition right now but just to be on
the cool off without me I'm gonna get
myself something without who's that
gonna get oh no this any of your
business but here's the deal I'm gonna
get me a blue cheese keeper I'm one of
the only Magic Trackpad
keyboard a magic trick pendant on your
wife remarkable
[Music]
Oh mr. YouTube you sure changuk retching
well not at work today mr. YouTube it's
Christmas Day you see VAT as a fit
excuse to rob me of my cursor but I mean
no sir but you said I could have the day
off I'll crush it
I won't stand for this kind of behavior
and oh please and therefore some go
crush it I am prepared to raise your
salary sir yes sir sound guy raise your
salary and promise to purchase you a new
iMac and to properly monetize all of
taurine okay Darren's videos for this
Christmas and everyone Hereafter
Merry Christmas mr. you too piss off
and so it was said of Ebenezer YouTube
that he was no longer a dick
unfortunately he had alienated all of
his colleagues who built his great
fortune before him and they went forth
and kept the original spirit of YouTube
in their hearts all year round and they
kept it well as for Ebenezer YouTube
well it would rather seem he screwed the
pooch
[Music]
you